how can we explain
um
what is going on in america that we have
the leaders that we do today
so the if we think about the
elections of the past several cycles
i guess let me ask are we a divided
nation are we more of a divided nation
than war in the past
what
do you understand about the american
citizen at the beginning of this century
from the leaders we have elected
yes obviously we are a divided country
in our rhetoric
um
in
our
day-to-day politics um
but
we are nowhere near as divided as we
have been in other periods in our
history right the most obvious of course
being in the american civil war right
150 years ago
and
the distinction is not just that you
know we haven't come to blows um but
that we are fundamentally one society
one economy um and sort of you know
deeply integrated um as a nation um both
domestically and on the world stage in
ways that um you know look nothing like
the united states uh in 1861.
um you know will there be um you know
will political rhetoric um continue to
be extreme of course um
but uh but but we're we're not as
divided as people think we are
[Applause]
well
um then
if you actually look throughout human
history does it always get so outside
the people do the elections get
as contentious as they've recently been
um so there's a kind of perception has
been very close and there's
a lot of accusations a lot of tensions
it's very heated it's almost fueling the
machine of division has that often been
the case
it has we are
it hasn't hasn't i mean i do think right
now is is different um and there it's
worth distinguishing
you know are there deep social or
economic divisions which i don't
actually think that there are versus
partisanship in particular sort of the
rivalry between the two parties and it's
very clear that we are in an era of what
we what political scientists call hyper
partisanship right and that the two
parties have taken um
fundamentally different positions and
moved further
you know apart from one another
and
you know and that is
what i think people talk about when they
say our country is divided so the
country may not be divided even if our
politics are highly partisan
that is uh you know a divergence from
from other time periods in our history
so i wonder if this kind of political
partisanship
is actually
an illusion of division
i sometimes feel like
we mostly all agree
on some basic fundamentals
and and the things that people allegedly
disagree on are really blown out of
proportion and there's like a media
machine and the politicians really want
you to pick
a blue side and the red side and because
of that
somehow i mean families break up over
thanksgiving dinner about who they voted
for there's a really strong pressure to
be the red or blue
and
i wonder if that's a feature or a bug
whether this is just part of the
mechanism of democracy that we want to
even if there's not a real thing to be
divided over we need to construct it
such that you can always have a tension
of id attention of ideas
in order to
make progress to figure out how to
progress as a nation
i think we're figuring that out in real
time right on the one hand it's uh it's
easy to say that it's a feature of uh of
a political system
that has two parties right um and the
united states is in some ways unique
right in
in not being a parliamentary democracy
and so in some ways it you would think
that would be the feature that is
causing
uh partisanship and to reach these
heights
that said
um you know we can even see in
parliamentary systems and you know all
around the world uh that the same kinds
of
um rhetorics of of irreconcilable
division a kind of politics of emotion
um are proliferating around the world
um some of that um as you say i think is
is
not as real as as it appears on on
television on social media and other
formats
so you know i don't i don't know that
other countries are um that are
experiencing sort of political conflict
i'm not sure that they're deeply divided
either
so
i've uh had the
fortune
of being intellectually active through
the george bush versus al gore election
than the obama and just every election
since right
and it seems like a large percentage of
those elections
there's been a claim that the elections
were rigged
that there is some
conspiracy corruption malevolence on the
on the other side i distinctly remember
when donald trump won in 2016
a lot of
people i know said that election was
rigged and there's different
explanations including russian
influence
and then in 2020 i was just running in
in austin
along the river
and somebody said like oh huge fan
of the podcast and they said like what
do you think of it this is just not
right what's happening in this country
that um the 2020 election was obviously
rigged
from their perspective
in
electing joe biden versus donald trump
do you think there's a case to be made
for and against each claim
in the full context of history
of
our elections being rigged
i think
the american election system is
fundamentally
sound
and reliable
and i think that the
evidence
you know is is clear for that um you
know regardless of which uh election
you're looking at in some ways whether
even you know you look at a presidential
election or even a local you know county
election for dog catcher or something
right
that the
um you know the amount of sort of time
and resources and precision that go into
voter registration vote counting
certification processes
are
crucial to
democratic institutions
i think when someone says
rigged
regardless of which side of the
political spectrum they're coming from
um
they're looking
for an answer
that you know they're looking for that
one answer
for what is in fact a complex system
right so you know on the left when they
say rigged
they may be pointing to a wide range of
um
of ways in which they think that the
system
um is is tilted um through you know
gerrymandering uh
you know sort of misrepresentation
through the electoral college
on the right when people say rigged they
may be concerned
you know about
about
you know sort of voter security about
ways in which the media pre-made you
know mainstream media may control
messages
and in which you know in both cases
the feeling is um my
it's articulated as my vote didn't get
counted right
um but the deeper concern is
my my vote doesn't count you know my
voice
isn't being heard
um so
so no i don't think i don't think the
elections are rigged so let me sort of
push back right
there's a comfort to the story that
they're not
and a lot of us like to live in comfort
so people who articulate conspiracy
theories say sure it's nice to be
comfortable but here's the reality
and the thing they articulate is there's
incentives in close elections which we
seem to have non-stop close elections
there's so many financial interests
there's so many powerful people
surely you can construct not just with
the media
and all the ways you describe both on
the left and the right the elections
could be rigged but literally
actually
in an
fully illegal way
manipulate the results of
votes
surely there's incentive to do that
and
i don't think that's
uh that's a totally ridiculous argument
because it's like all right well
um i mean it actually lands
to the
question
which is a hard question for me to ask
us ultimately as an optimist
of
how many malevolent people out there and
how many malevolent people are required
to rig an election
so how many what is the face transition
for a system to become from like uh
corruption light to corruption
uh to high level of corruption such that
you could do things like regulations
which is what happens
quite a lot in many nations in um in the
world even today
so yes there is interference in
elections and there has been in american
history right and we can go all the way
back into the the you know into the 18th
century um you don't have to go back to
you know texas in the 1960s uh lbj to to
find examples of of direct interference
in the outcome of elections and there
are incentives to do that those
incentives will only feel more
existential
as hyperpartisanship
makes people think that the outcome of
the elections are
you know are
are a matter of you know black and white
or life and death
um
and um you will see people sort of
organizing sort of um uh every way they
can to shape elections right we saw this
in the 1850s right when settlers you
know pro and anti-slavery sort of
flooded into kansas
to try to sort of uh you know uh
determine the outcome of an election and
we see this in the reconstruction period
right when the klu klux klan shows up to
kind of you know to block the doors for
for black voters in the south
um you know that the with this history
is not new it's it's there
um i think what um
what the reason why i think that the
system is sound is um is not or the
reason when i say i believe that the
election system is fundamentally sound
um it's not um i'm not trying to be
reassuring um or encourage complacency
right i'm saying like you know this is
something that we need to to do and to
work on
so the current electoral mechanisms
are are
sufficiently robust
even if there is corruption even if
there is rigging they're robot like uh
the force that corrects it self corrects
and ensures that nobody gets out of line
is much stronger than the other
incentives which are like the corrupting
incentives and that's the thing i um
talked about corrupt you know visiting
ukraine talking about corruption
where a lot of people talk about
corruption as being a symptom not if the
system allows
creates the incentives
for there to be corruption humans will
always go for corruption that's just you
have to assume that the power of the
united states is that it constructs
systems that
prevent you from being corrupt at scale
at least i mean depends what you believe
but most of us
if you believe in this country you have
to
you believe in the in the
self-correcting mechanisms of corruption
that uh even if that desire is in the
human heart
the system resists it prevents it
that's that's your
that's your current belief uh
yes as of today
but i do you know i do think that those
um you know the that will require
oversight by institutions ideally
ones that are insulated as much as
possible from partisan politics which is
very difficult right now
um and it will require uh
the demands of of the american people
and that they you know that they want um
these elections to be
to be fair and secure and and that means
you know that means uh being willing to
lose them um you know regardless of
which which party you're you're in favor
of so what do you think about the power
of the media to create partisanship i'm
really worried that there's a huge
incentive speaking of incentives
to divide the country
in the
in the media and the politicians i'm not
sure where it originates but it feels
like it's the media maybe it's a very
cynical perspective on journalism but
it seems like if we're angry and divided
as evenly as possible you're going to
maximize the number of clicks
so it's almost like the media wants to
elect people that are going to be the
most uh
divisive maximizing
and
the worry i have
is they
are not beyond
either feeding or if you want to be very
cynical manufacturing narratives
that lead that division like the
narrative of an election being rigged
because if you convinced half the
populist that the election was
completely rigged
that's a really good way
to get a lot of clicks
and and like
the very cynical view
is i don't know if the media machine
will stop the destruction of our
democracy
uh in service of getting more clicks
it may destroy our entire democracy just
to get more clicks just uh because the
fire as the thing burns down
will get clicks
is am i putting too much blame on the
media here
the machine of it you're diagnosing the
incentive structure um i don't know
you're depicting that with 100
accuracy but uh i think history teaches
that you might be giving the media too
much um sort of causal power
um that uh you know that the american
people are smarter than the media that
they consume right and um you know and
even even today we we know that right
people who consume
you know even people who consume just
fox or just msnbc
um know what they're consuming right um
uh and you know so i don't think that
media will be
the solution um
and i certainly don't think that
returning to
a media structure of the mid 20th
century with you know three news
channels that all tell us one story
is that's no golden age that we're
trying to get back to
uh
for sure well there's a there is a novel
thing in human history which is twitter
and social media and so on
so we're trying to find our footing as a
nation to figure out how to think about
politics how to um yeah how to
maintain
our basic freedoms our sense of uh
democracy of our interaction with
government and so on on this new media
where
medium of social media
do you think twitter
how do you think twitter changed things
you think twitter is good for democracy
and do you think it has changed what it
means to be an american citizen
uh or is it just the same old media
mechanism it has not changed what it
means to be an american citizen um it
has uh it may have changed the um
the the day-to-day
sound of of being and you know the the
experience of it got noisier it got
louder
um and it got more
de-centered
i think
twitter is a
it's paradoxical on the one hand it is a
fundamentally democratic uh platform
right you know any and in some ways it
democratizes institutions that um you
know that had
had gatekeepers and and you know
authority figures for a very long time
but on the other hand it's it's not a
democratic institution at all it's a
for-profit corporation
and you know it operates under under
those principles
um and so you know that said it's it's a
you know is an institution of american
and global life
and that the people
of of the united states have uh have the
authority to to
regulate or reshape as as they see fit
both that and and other major media
players so one of the most dramatic
decisions that illustrate both sides of
what you're saying
is when twitter decided to ban i think
permanently
the president of united states donald
trump off of twitter
can you
make the case that that was a good idea
and make the case that that was a bad
idea can you see both perspective on
this
yes i think
i mean the simple fact of the matter is
um
you know twitter is a platform it has uh
rules of service uh twitter concluded
that president trump had violated the
terms of service and and blocked them
right and if you have roles you have to
enforce them
um
did it have um you know did it have
consequences um
it had
direct and predictable consequences
you know that
of
creating
a sense among millions of americans that
twitter
had taken aside in politics
or confirming their their belief that it
had done so
um will it have unintended consequences
um you know this is where the historian
can come in and say yes um there's
always unintended consequences and we
don't know you know sort of what um what
it would mean um for political figures
to be excluded from from
various media platforms
um under sort of under under these
notions right of um that they had
violated terms of service etc so you
know
so
i guess we'll see as i guess well to me
so i'm generally against censorship
uh but to take twitter's perspective
it's unclear to me
in terms of unintended consequences
whether censoring a human being
from being part of your platform
is going to
decrease or increase the amount of hate
in the world
so
there's a strong case to be made that
banning somebody like donald trump
increases the amount of resentment
among people
and that's a very large number of people
that support him or even love him or
even see him as a great president one of
the greatest this country has had
and so if you completely suppress his
voice
you're going to intensify the
support
that he has
from just the regular support for
another human being who ran for
president
to
somebody that becomes an almost heroic
figure for that
set of people
now the flip side is
removing
a person from a platform like donald
trump
might lessen the megaphone of that
particular person might actually
uh level
the
the democratic notion that everybody has
a voice so basically removing the loud
extremes
is helpful for giving
the center
the calm
the thoughtful voices more power and so
in that sense that teaches a lesson that
don't be crazy in any one direction
don't go
full don't go lenin don't go
uh hitler don't don't
like you have to stay in the middle
there's divisions in the middle there's
discussions in the middle but stay in
the middle
that's sort of the steel man the case
for uh for censoring
but i
boy
is censorship a slippery slope
and also boys twitter becoming
a thing that's more than just a company
it seems like it's a medium of
communication that we use
for um
for information for
for knowledge for wisdom even
you know during the period of covid
we used it to gain an understanding of
what the hell is going on what should we
do what's the state-of-the-art science
science fundamentally transformed during
the time of code because you have no
time for the full review cycle that
science usually goes through and some of
the best sources of information for me
from the conspiracy theory to the the
best doctors was twitter
the data the stats all that kind of
stuff and
that feels like like more than a com
more than a company and then twitter and
youtube and different places took a
really strong stance on kovid
which
is the lazy stance in my opinion which
is we're going to listen to whatever
cdc or the institutions have said
but the reality is
you're an institution of your own now
you're kind of the press
you're like there's a there's a um
yes it's a really difficult position
it's a really really difficult position
to take uh but i i wish they have
stepped up and take on the full
responsibility and the pain
of fighting for the freedom of speech
yes they need uh
they need to do that um
but um
you know i'm struck by some of the
things that you said ways in which
you know
twitter
has the power to shape the conversation
um
and i don't think in a democratic
society uh
democratic polities should cede that
power
um to to for-profit uh companies do you
agree that it's possible that
twitter
has that power currently do you sense
that it has the power is that my senses
twitter is the power star wars
like tweets have the power to start wars
to to
yeah to to change the direction of
elections
maybe in the sense in the ways in which
uh you know a wave has the power to wash
away sand right um you know it's it's
the meat it's still the medium right
it's not um
it's not in itself an actor it's how
actors use the platform
which requires us to scrutinize the
structure of the platform and access to
it unfortunately it's not maybe as
similar to the wave it's not just a
medium it's a
it's a medium plus
it's a medium that enables virality
that benefits from virality of
engagement and that means
singular voices
can
can have a disproportionate impact
like uh not even voices singular ideas
dramatic ideas can have a
disproportionate impact and so that
actually threatens
it's almost like i don't know what the
equivalent is in nature but it's a it's
a wave that can grow exponentially
because of the intensity of the
the initial
intensity of the wave
um i don't know how to describe it as a
dynamical system but it feels like
it feels like there there is a
responsibility there not to excel not to
accelerate voices just because they get
a lot of engagement you have to have a
proportional representation of that
voice
um but you're saying that
a strong democracy should be robust to
that
uh a strong democracy uh can and should
and and will be i mean i think the other
thing a historian will tell you about
twitter is that this too shall pass yes
right
yeah
but um but i do think you know the
structures of of the of the platform of
the algorithm of of this and other major
players
um uh are
are
eligible for scrutiny by by democratic
institutions
you